[Music]
you know it's a great idea stuffing a
hundred players into a plane to
parachute down on a desolate island to
scavenge for weapons armor and supplies
in hopes of surviving a bloody
deathmatch throwing the impending doom
of an electric field that forces players
into an ever-shrinking warzone and you
get player unknowns battlegrounds this
foreboding gameplay concept results in
an exhilarating multiplayer shooter with
several randomized variables that
challenge you to adapt no one matches
the same and that's what keeps you
coming back for more
despite glaring technical flaws pugsy
emerges as the most accessible
streamlined battle royale game to date
gone are the more granular gameplay
elements of pub G's forebears like
crafting bleeding arduous navigation pub
G is a distilled version of the battle
royale style which makes learning curve
less steep jumping into a match is less
daunting and faster pace than something
like h1z1 king of the kill or earlier
armor mods you're expected to scavenge
for weapons ammo armor and health packs
these critical items litter the city
centres towns and abandoned structures
across the games two different maps
tension and anticipation fill the air
even in an early phase of a match you
have to account for your plane's flight
path and determine if you want to pick a
fight as soon as possible
then it's a race to find the first gun
or immediately throw hands in a
hilariously janky boxing match on the
flipside parachuting to a more distant
town results in a less stressful hunt
for equipment but you won't always get
the gear that you want in squads sharing
an abundance of ammo and health packs or
scouting to relocate highlights the
tactical advantage of team play even in
the opening minutes it's absolutely
necessary to juggle all of these factors
but by the same token this can prove to
be exhausting and repetitive despite
having relatively smooth inventory
management it's demoralizing to spend a
majority of a match gearing up only to
lose in the first firefight or die
unceremoniously from dissing gunfire but
that's the give-and-take you have to
accept in pub g4 the more rewarding
moments to surface
[Music]
[Music]
don't forget you have to face the dread
of the slow yet
ominous blue circle of death that forces
players into an increasingly smaller
zone regardless of the area you land in
the random nature of where the circle
converges within a huge map ensures that
no one matches exactly the same and many
shooters were captures owns and specific
choke points dictate the action pub G
leverages simple variables to stave off
monotony you never really know where the
final firefight will take place or which
position is most advantageous when
things heat up until the blue zone comes
into view positioning scouting and
knowing when to engage are incredibly
important for success
these are tenants that feed into the
emergent tactics formed in a matter of
seconds especially when playing in a
group spotting enemy movement presents
an opening for a kill that could turn
the tide of battle but you also risk
leaving yourself vulnerable pursue the
enemy and brace yourself for bullets
raining down or fire from afar and give
a position away to other players in the
event of getting knocked out teams can
revive you before you bleed out but
they're defenseless as the revived
countdown ticks pub G is a series of
calculated risks it's not entirely new
to video games but the unpredictability
of where and when these moments happen
keeps the game fresh as you inch toward
becoming the last combatant standing
tension ramps up exponentially the
risk/reward nature of pub G is
compounded by the fact that matches
become more of an investment as they go
on but because of how much you have to
work to achieve victory winning is
intrinsically rewarding even without a
tangible prize at the end
that's not to say that the only triumph
comes from winning though survival
itself is an achievement every kill
feels earned and recognizing mistakes in
a heated battle is a lesson learned pub
G retains some of the military
simulation roots of its predecessors and
the game is better for it guns aren't
easy to wield recoil is a major factor
that negates the effectiveness of full
auto firing modes outside of close
quarter encounters bullet drop makes
sniping much more challenging than
simply lining up your crosshairs health
packs take time to be applied which
makes you think twice about healing
under pressure but to experience the
most satisfying parts of pub G you'll
likely go through a lot of trial and
error as of now there aren't any in-game
tutorials to lay out the basics or jump
start newcomers even after several hours
you may still not realize something as
simple as the fact that you can hold the
ctrl key right-click items in the
inventory to drop specific quantities
for your squadmates battlegrounds lacks
technical refinement as well the game is
noticeably improved from its early
access days but frame rates can still
fluctuate inexplicably even a high NPC
can have trouble maintaining a steady
framerate with relatively modest
graphics settings evidence of the game's
ongoing optimisation issues on top of
the in-game performance problems the
fear of seemingly random crashes in
connection difficulties linger if and
when the strike a good match is ruined
the technical shortcomings of player
unknowns battlegrounds can undermine its
broader achievement however pub G
focuses on streamlining the core tenants
that make the genre so enjoyable each
phase of a match presents a different
type of tension its equal parts
thrilling and terrifying all driven by
the insatiable desire to be the last
person or squad standing
whether you play solo or in a group
successfully executing adaptive tactics
makes for an incredibly tense and
rewarding experience every player has
unique stories of their most memorable
matches and even after hundreds of hours
player unknowns battlegrounds keeps on
giving
[Music]
you
[Music]